hello and welcome to justice i'm judge
jeanine pirro thanks so much for being
with us tonight
and yes the rumors are true
we did it again last weekend justice was
number one the whole weekend long and
viewers all day saturday saturday night
sunday and sunday night so thanks for
keeping the streak alive
and tonight the odds are in our favor
again
i've got senate judiciary chairman
lindsey graham house minority leader
kevin mccarthy corey lewandowski former
congressman daryl isa charlie kirk
all with me live but first my open
this week we witnessed the difference
between a leader and a wannabe
the stark contrast between someone who
is a world leader
and someone who's hoping his day will
come
but being a leader takes vision
fortitude persistence
and a selflessness a dug-in
determination to a goal
that never changes by way of example
permit me to introduce you to a
non-leader the first united states
senator in american history to vote to
convict the president of his own party
mitt romney the sole and only republican
to vote to convict
president trump how dare
he how could he and why
would he mitt dared to do what he
thought was good for him
individually not for the party not for
us and certainly not for america
he knew his vote would change nothing
regarding impeachment
but he tried to set himself up as a
leader
going against everyone else he took a
stand he thought would impress others
it did many on the loony left defended
him
saying his vote was very patriotic
yes he endeared himself to the trump
hating left the radicals not interested
in the america first agenda
the ones who are all about power not
truth
so why mitt says his strong
faith is a reason and that god demanded
it of me
my promise before god
to apply impartial justice required that
i put my personal feelings
and political biases aside
were i to ignore the evidence that has
been presented
and disregard what i believe my oath and
the constitution demands of me
for the sake of a partisan end it would
i fear
expose my character to history's rebuke
look i'm catholic i went to catholic
schools and i believe in god
do you ever wonder why people who never
mention god or religion
only bring it up when they get caught
doing something or when they need an
excuse for something they did
kind of like nancy pelosi who so hates
donald trump that she almost has a
conniption
when she tries to get us to believe she
prays for him
every day and does not hate him
who do these people think they're
fooling
what a bunch of phonies i can't wait to
hear what they're going to tell saint
peter when they get there
but let me move on from his religious to
his secular reason
i sought to hear sought to hear
testimony from john bolton
not only because i believed he could add
context to the charges
but also because i hoped that what he
might say
could raise reasonable doubt meant a
primer
the transcript of the telephone call
which no one expected the president
would release
is the corpus it is the body of the
alleged
wrongdoing anything before after
around it is irrelevant in the material
what was said in that conversation is
what acquits or convicts the president
curious you use bolton as an excuse to
convict
when you don't even know what he's going
to say and when the prosecutors haven't
even made out a prima facie approvable
case
mr wannabe did you ask or even wonder
why the democrat house managers didn't
subpoena bolton
when the prosecution doesn't present
evidence that you want
and you don't have the slightest idea
what that evidence might be
or whether it's even relevant you want
to use
that nothing burger to convict the
president of the united states
are you stupid too you take
non-evidence that the democrats refuse
to present as the reason to convict the
president
in an economy that is unparalleled with
a military whose strength is
unequaled with a population where 90
percent
are happy with their lives you really
are
stupid you use the prosecutor's
inability to make a case as a reason to
vote guilty
run that one by america again mitt
the facts before you make it clear there
was no pressure no demands no ukrainian
investigation
where the money was actually delivered
before required
where our president under an
international treaty had the right to
ask for help
in fact and an obligation to investigate
corruption
especially where united states taxpayers
money
goes to foreign countries and you
say this is the most difficult decision
you've ever made
meant you're full of it and since you're
such a scholar
did you ever consider the president's
constitutional rights
that were stripped from him in the star
chamber where he was denied the
presumption of innocence
the truth is mitt you simply despise
donald trump your jealousy of this man
is a constant rage burning within you
because you can never rise to the
heights
that he has because guys like you
fold like wusses and you don't have any
selflessness
or the ability to think about others as
donald trump has thought about making
america first
and by the way you're an embarrassment
i should know i said it four years ago
your namby-pamby reason that you won't
support donald trump
even if he's the party's nominee you
worry what you'll tell your
grandchildren when they asked
why grandpa didn't you stop donald trump
well maybe you ought to worry about when
they ask about your loss to barack obama
what are you going to tell them will you
tell them that you
choked mit
losers choke you choked when a cnn
reporter pushed back on you
and you folded like every other loser
and you always talk about your
grandchildren what you'll say to them
you just did it again
you ought to think about telling that
that you're the reason barack obama got
four more years
with an economy in the tank a caliphate
that was growing
law enforcement and military morale in
the garbage
you haven't always been able to hide the
real you
in fact the people who knew you best
when you ran
the people of massachusetts voted
against you
it was one of the worst home state
losses in presidential history
and your arrogance again on full display
i do believe it should be removed from
office really meant
he should be removed from office he
should be removed from office for what
so you can try to make another move for
president i've got news for you
you got no moves left at your request
donald trump supported you in 2012 and
and like a snake in the grass you turned
on him
i have an idea you need to be removed
from office
how about you get the hell out of the
united states senate
the people in utah are furious with you
and your dream of endearing yourself to
the trump-hating
left is a joke so mitt
pack your bags take some time off
and ride around with your dog on the
roof of your car like you did when you
used to vacation with your family
and don't forget when you lie with dogs
you get fleas but that'll never be as
bad as the stain
you have forged upon whatever legacy
you think you have
that's my open let me let me know what
you think on facebook
twitter judge jeanine